hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
struggling to reach a deal cop 27
negotiations will continue into the
weekend
weeks of rainfall in days across Britain
as Australia is hit by flooding for the
second time in a month
an environmental group say the
government's Autumn statement has fallen
woefully short of tackling climate
change
[Music]
foreign hello and welcome to the Daily
climate show where we track the changes
to our world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
talks at cop27 in Egypt should have been
finishing with an agreement this
afternoon but there's little sign of a
deal at the moment all the indications
are that talks will continue into the
weekend and there are still huge
differences between nations on how to
tackle climate change in a moment we'll
have the latest from the talks in
charmele Sheikh but first a reminder of
what politicians and diplomats were
hoping for at the start of the talks on
November the 6th
so the Secretary General of the UN
Antonio guterres this is what he said at
the beginning of cop27 I am calling for
a historic pact between developed and
emerging economies a climate solidarity
pact this pact will be one in which all
countries make an extra effort to reduce
emissions this decade in line with the
1.5 degree goal the two largest
economies the United States and China
have a particular responsibility to join
efforts to make this pact a reality
well the Prime Minister of Barbados Mia
Motley was she focused on reparations
for developing nations saying there is
no way that developing countries can
fight this battle without access to
concessional funding we believe that it
is critical we address the issue of loss
and damage how do companies make 200
billion dollars in profits in the last
three months and not expect to
contribute at least 10 cents on every
dollar to a loss and damage fund this is
what our people expect meanwhile the
environmental campaigner and former U.S
vice president Al Gore has said we have
a credibility problem all of us we're
talking and we're starting to act but
we're not doing enough we must see the
so-called dash for gas for what it
really is a dash down a bridge to
nowhere leaving the countries of the
world facing climate chaos and billions
in stranded assets especially here in
Africa we have to move beyond the era of
fossil fuel colonialism
now one possible breakthrough at the
talks has been on the issue of
compensation for poorer countries
affected by climate change this morning
as smaller Nations insisted a deal had
to be reached the EU said it would be
willing to contribute to a so-called
loss and damage fund
I have to say this is our final offer
this is where the member states can find
an agreement and I I have to thank all
of them for for the courage to go to go
this far but this is it this is about
not having a failure here we we cannot
afford to have a failure now if our
steps forward are not reciprocated then
obviously there will be a failure but I
hope I hope we can avoid that
these processes are difficult when
you're trying to create something new it
takes time and what we have to measure
is how willing all partners are in
getting and overcome their difficulties
we are identifying the areas that we
think need adjusting and there's a
process to do this
and I cannot get into those details I
cannot negotiate on the media so we'll
wait until we meet on bilaterally to
discuss the areas of concern
all right well let's get the very latest
from cop27 Tom Heap from the climate
show is in charmele Shake
hi Tom so Friday is coming to an end
where are we with this agreement
still not there the the wire is being uh
is being bent is being stretched we've
definitely uh well very very unlikely to
get an agreement today but as you say I
am here in this extraordinary Hive of
humanity big sprawling area of people
trying to do their best too if you like
save the world but I am a bit of a new
boy a bit of a Johnny come lately in
comparison to Victoria Seabrook our
climate reporter Victoria you've been
here for more than 14 days you must be
really really in immersed in it by now
yes it does start to feel a bit like
Groundhog Day once you've been here for
a while but thankfully things are really
ramping up now as we as we get close to
the finish so the adrenaline Gets You
Through towards the end well what are
those things approaching the Finish Line
what are the things still under debate
yeah so we've had um movement on two key
things that that we really needed to see
if there was going to be a you know a
good outcome here really yeah and that's
happened in the last 24 hours so one of
the key issues is what we've heard so
much about here which is about who pays
for climate impacts climate damages in
vulnerable countries things like the
flooding in Pakistan because I heard
just 24 hours ago Antonio Gutierrez you
know boss of un came and said you know
there was a breakdown of trust between
the North and South of this and we
needed to Stand and Deliver great praise
um and there has been some movement
since then yes that's right he actually
jetted straight from the G20 he'd
already been here last week and decided
to come back to try and give the talks a
little bit of momentum what's happened
on that key issue is
that there's been a rift really up until
yesterday with on the one hand
developing countries saying we need a
fund to pay when climate disasters
strike and developed countries on the
other hand saying yes okay we
acknowledge that there needs to be some
some funding but we're not we we think
that actually it should be much broader
than just a fund there's lots of other
levers that we can pull they were really
at loggerheads up until about yesterday
and then yesterday evening potentially
there has there has been a big
breakthrough we'll see how it plays out
but essentially the EU sort of offered
to meet in the middle and said yes okay
we'll do a fund but with two important
tweaks and those tweaks I gather there
to do with who the money goes to the
most vulnerable and making sure it
reaches those really in need that's one
of them yes that's exactly it so the
existing idea had very um very sort of
stiff lines developed countries
developing countries developed to pay in
and the fund pays out for developing
countries and the eu's big issue with
this was saying well that list is old
and that would see China a class in the
developing country we need to Target it
to the most vulnerable countries so
that's one of their suggestions and I
gather another one that's kind of
broadening the scope of kind of who pays
so it's not just kind of the taxpayers
of the rich North but some other
institutions or mechanisms as well yes
that's exactly it Innovative sources of
finances we're hearing so much about so
it's not just countries paying into the
pot of money it's pulling other levers
so it's thing thing ideas that they've
suggested is things like levees on
frequent flyers on on shipping on these
very
polluting carbon intensive Industries
skimming money off those fossil fuel
production and saying let's use all
these sources not just countries paying
in and the other thing I find really
interesting about that is it's also not
just looking at it if you like
historical guilt in inverted commas it's
looking at what's actually emitting
today which I I'm feeling might be a
slightly easier sell to a lot of richer
Nations
um but I wanted to move on as well
there's a lot that goes on here that
isn't just about the top level
politicians and this final cover text
isn't there and people are quite
optimistic about that yes exactly so
you've got the the pure process the
hardcore negotiations diplomats
ministers and so on but you can think of
it as like a center of gravity around
which we've got all of these other
things circling so a lot of what is
achieved here is not just what happens
behind closed doors in these
um dimly lit negotiating rooms in the
wee hours it's also big deals on on
offshore wind on zero emission Vehicles
all these other sectors that really need
to get in line if we are going to curb
warming
Victoria thank you very much indeed so
we shouldn't hang all of our hopes and
fears on that final copy text other
things as well
Victoria thank you very much and back to
you
okay Tom thanks so much
right in other news today the Met Office
says that parts of the UK have seen
three weeks worth of rain in just 24
hours there have been more downpours
today especially in eastern Scotland
where more than 80 millimeters of
rainfall has been recorded in two days
and a warning after a mainly dry weekend
more rain is expected across the country
early next week
for the second time in a month part of
Southeastern Australia have been hit by
Major flooding rural parts of New South
Wales are said to be the worst affected
after three days of torrential rain
officials are warning the Lachlan River
could reach a 70-year high of just under
11 meters for the second time in the
last month
Regulators in the U.S have approved a
500 million dollar plan to demolish four
dams in California it'll be the largest
dam removal and River restoration
project in the world and it's something
environmentalists and Native American
tribes have long campaigned for the aim
is to reopen a large section of the
Klamath River for the first time in more
than a century improving salmon stocks
and increasing hydroelectric power isn't
that beautiful
now the Autumn statement provided a
range of climate change announcements
including plans to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions from buildings by 15 within 10
years but friends of the Earth have said
the government's plans fell woefully
short well Jess Ralston is from the
non-profit group the energy and climate
intelligence unit and she joins us now
so Jess thanks for joining us woefully
short but short of what and do you agree
well as far we can tell so far the
Autumn statement has a lot of measures
in it talking about green things but
actually in the details they're not
actually delivering very much of that
this year next year or the year after
it's mostly things from 2025 and Beyond
which we're looking at and so for the
immediate crisis that we're in right now
there's not all that much help for Bill
payers hmm okay he did say though the
chancellor when he made that statement
that now would be the wrong time to step
back from our International climate
responsibilities that does sound
positive regardless of whether it's now
or two years down the line
yes the government rhetoric on this is
that they are committed to climate and
committed to Net Zero and which is
obviously positive considering that's
what the climate change committee think
we need to do by 2015 in order to curve
global warming
um but there is still a lot to be done
in this country you know our homes are
very leaky we waste a lot of energy and
during this current gas crisis and Bill
payers and taxpayers are looking to the
government for leadership on those sorts
of
measures
uh there's there there is so much
rhetoric obviously about insulating our
homes in that statement the chancellor
promised an extra six billion pounds to
improve Energy Efficiency Yes again by
2025 but that's a concrete step
well it seems like it but when you look
at what's happening with the political
polls the conservatives are you know
they're falling behind labor on a lot of
the polls and almost all of them I
believe
um so by the time 2025 comes around
there is a large question mark over
whether Jeremy Hunt uh where she seen
that the Tories in general whether
they'll actually be in charge so there's
some people who are saying that these
are easy promises and when the situation
in 2025 might be that they're not even
in power why do you think that they
haven't committed to doing it from now
I really don't know and that's probably
a question uh better posed to the
government because all of the experts
you know even fuel poverty groups
um the CCC everybody has been saying for
years that it's a good idea to sort out
our leaky homes and given the current
gas crisis you know there's public
demand for it as well people want to do
these things people want to fix up their
home so they can save energy and save
money on bills but they're not being
offered the kind of support that we're
seeing in many other European countries
and it really is you know a large
question mark over why that's the case
now that the base secretary the business
energy and Industrial uh strategy
secretary is due to make another
statement in the coming weeks
um around Energy Efficiency and around
energy demand reduction and but so forth
so far what we're seeing from the
government is a lot of talking and a lot
not a lot of walking and so it might be
that we see more in the coming weeks but
so far there's a large question mark
okay concrete step they did um hike the
windfall tax surely must be pleased with
that step
well the windfall tax you know lots of
the public are thinking that's a fair
thing to do given the large profits that
the oil and gas companies are making
during the gas crisis and but when it
comes to the renewable electricity
generation tax and the renewable sector
are a little bit baffled by this because
the oil and gas sector get taxpayer
money back for investing in new oil and
gas whereas the renewable electricity
generators don't get anything for
investing in new renewable electricity
and so there's a bit of a backward step
there when quite clearly the solution to
the gas crisis is moving away from gas
and moving to more Renewables and this
this loophole for the oil and gas
companies that's not present for the
renewable generators that's a bit of a
thing where the businesses are saying
you know this doesn't make any sense
considering you need us to invest in
order to get to Net Zero and so there's
questions again about the windfall tax
but one step they did take was to reduce
that loophole so instead of making 81p
in the pound they only make 29 or 30 GP
so they've reduced it but there's still
an incentive there to invest in new oil
and gas and that doesn't make much sense
when we need to get away from it in
order to get away from the gas crisis
and to reach Net Zero okay Jess thank
you so much for talking to us
and before we go a reminder that Tom is
going to be presenting a special climate
show he's as you saw in charm or Sheikh
this weekend focusing on the end of
cop27 and what if anything gets achieved
you can watch that show on Saturday on
Saturday and Sunday at 7 30 pm
and the daily climate show will be back
on Monday at half past three have a good
weekend and until then goodbye
[Music]